[Music]
foreign
she was like family
she was the only person who ever took
care of me
I just got a message saying that there's
a problem with my computer yes ma'am we
got this
yesterday she shot herself
this is private property do you know
what they do here scamming the weakest
in our society buddy I'm counting three
one two three
yeah I did it for you
[Music]
I'm gonna burn this place to the ground
will you stomp his ass out
you're telling me one man did this the
only thing you know it is a beekeeper
a beekeeper beekeeper well that's not
good
beekeepers is a special program outside
the chain of commands and protect the
hive when the system is out of balance
I correct it we have laws for these
things until they fail then you have me
five fingers to cut them off oh what the
[__] bro don't move
this is much bigger than a little
fishing skin
the money's going all over the world to
people in finance even government
I figured I'd get the firefighters a
break somebody entertain this guy
we have to kill him before he kills his
way to the top
honey
it's flammable as [__] who knew
[Music]
foreign